stop worshiping celebrities so much just
don't let's don't pay attention
i remember right around september 11th
uh ja rule
was on mtv that's what they said we got
y'all rule on the phone
let's see what jaws thoughts are on this
tragedy gives a [ __ ] with john rule
thinks at a time like this [ __ ] this is
ridiculous
i don't want to dance i'm scared to
death
i want some answers that john rule might
not have right now
i think when bad [ __ ] happens to me i'll
be in the crib like oh my god this is
terrible
because nobody please find y'all rule
get hold of this [ __ ] so i can
make sense of all this
where is job
i have to meet y'all rule
i don't even know why people listen to
me
i'll say anything [ __ ] i've done
commercials for coke
and pepsi i don't give a [ __ ] what comes
out of my mouth i just say what it takes
whatever it takes that's what i'm saying
if you want to know the truth can't even
taste the difference
surprise all i know was pepsi paid me
most recently so
it tastes better that's pretty much how
the game goes
i'm just being real man there's too much
gugging over celebrities people don't
know
it was fake and what's real anymore
that's why bill cosby got in trouble
look what happened to bill cosby bill
cosby says some real [ __ ]
and the whole world freaked out on
for what for having an opinion just
because he was selling pudding pops for
the last 40 years
people forget that he's a [ __ ] from
philly in the projects and he might say
some real [ __ ] from time to time
it's not that big of a deal i spoke at
my old high school and i told them kids
straight up
if you guys are serious about making it
out of this ghetto
you got to focus you got to stop blaming
white people for your problems
and you've you've got to learn how to
rap or play basketball or something
[ __ ] you're trapped you are trapped
either do that or sell crap that's your
only option that's the only way i've
ever seen it work
you better get to entertaining these
white people
go on out there and be somebody
i just hope they listen
[Music]
this [ __ ] is ridiculous people worship
television they worship this [ __ ]
you know like if you watch a movie right
say you're watching a movie
and one character sends another
character say hey uh what's your number
man
what's the other character always say
stupid 555-5555 people go to the movies
and then go home and try to call the
characters
that they just saw hello is indiana
jones here no
[ __ ] he's fake it's not his
number
and to be honest this is the worst time
in history to be a black celebrity [ __ ]
they locking all our stars up
it's hot right now for black celebrities
i knew it was bad when kobe got in
trouble i said this is a wrap for us
he's one of the most wholesome dudes we
had
lock them up everything
kobe kept it together thank god he he
held his game together because if he was
cracking under pressure and getting like
six points a game
the whole l.a would have been like that
[ __ ] is guilty
[Applause]
kobe was playing his ass off he was
playing like his
freedom depended on that [ __ ] you see
this [ __ ]
game this [ __ ] trying to beat that case
on the court
like the judge tuned the ball like play
for your freedom
[Applause]
hollywood celebs shut the [ __ ] up
this week in celebrity virtue signaling
hollywood's a list and by a i mean
anonymous to be honest you didn't
recognize half of them either
got together and made an isis hostage
video to solve racism i take
responsibility every not so funny joke
every time i remain silent i take
responsibility
thank you hollywood i mean who better to
end systemic oppression than a cartoon
turtle lesbos steve jobs and this chick
who i'm told is kesha this is the most
insincere
empty self-serving piece of slacktivism
since
i don't know three months ago when they
did the exact same [ __ ]
so are these the celebs that can't sing
and i know what you're thinking actors
just shut the [ __ ] up and say the words
the ugly people wrote for you
unfortunately that's what they did here
yeah they didn't even write it
how are you going to tell us to take
responsibility when you can't even
take responsibility for your own
statement matter of fact they couldn't
even take responsibility
to memorize the lines which is exactly
what they're overpaid to do for a living
you need a teleprompter to say why
racism is bad
i cannot believe they're reading the
lines this [ __ ] brought her bifocals
and so did this [ __ ]
i will no longer allow stereotypes to be
uttered in my presence
you will no longer allow stereotypes you
play the sassy gay sidekick in
every movie stereotypes paid for your
house in the hills where you avoid black
people
no stereotypes stanley you're a 60 year
old italian man how else are you gonna
describe the people that move into your
neighborhood
and aaron paul you are breaking my
[ __ ] heart man what are you doing i
take responsibility
how about you take a sip of water what's
up with your voice you play pink man not
batman relax
at least i know who he is some of these
celebrities i've never seen before
every time i remain silent who the [ __ ]
is this guy anthony boring
speaking of parts unknown what's up with
your hair you coming with a pineapple
actors this is why we don't believe you
when you're at the oscars babbling on
about the horrors of the dairy industry
we know it's self-serving performative
[ __ ]
you get an award for pretending to be
something you're not and now you're up
there
pretending to be something you're not i
mean leonardo dicaprio goes on about
global warming but he probably punched a
hole in the ozone layer flying [ __ ]
around the planet
why do you think they call the airline
virgin it's disingenuous
you don't care about these issues you
care about the bag
disney professed their support for black
lives matter but then reduced john
boyega's role in the chinese release of
star wars because it was
better for the target audience and china
you're okay with yoda in the movie but
not a black guy
disney also has long advocated for gay
pride but then cut out the gay scenes
from the chinese release of bohemian
rhapsody
china you're okay with a bet in your
mouth but not a dick
now don't get me wrong market the movie
in the way that makes you and your
shareholders the most money get your
cash
but if you're gonna bend to a
totalitarian dictatorship that doesn't
value human rights
save us the [ __ ] lecture about ethics
but i don't think it's as simple as that
the thing is that ellen is uh
not a popular person she's kind of a
rotten uh
smelly awful she sucks
she's she's i wish we were on xm so i
could describe her completely
of course but i can't wait what have you
heard the fcc cannot
uh would not let her be accurately
described this is interesting don't be
like if a cop said who
shot you when it was hard you'd be like
you got to take me off the air because
like yeah
jimmy met her in vegas so this is really
interesting because he got the big blow
off
she was doing something for xm and we
were out there for example so i was like
i was like i woke up and she was being
filmed i'm like hey
i was you know i get my pictures with
everybody it's just what i do you didn't
get a picture with me i've met you twice
now yeah but i
you i'm too nervous to ask okay so i
walked up to uh
i walked up to ellen and i'm like hey
you know i'm a comic i'm also doing
something next time i just want to get a
quick picture so god no i can't i'm in
the middle of shooting
and she but she wasn't and i wanted to
spit in her face yeah she's
really good trashing if that's any
consolation good for you
i know people that work for her as
writers and she's yeah she's
uh she's a dope and uh mean to people oh
easy
on the language you know what i mean
yeah she's a spoiled sport she's a real
ninny she's a right rocker isn't she yes
she's a right writer yeah
most definitely i went to commercial i
was reading recently and she yelled at
her writers why did you write that for
me
yeah she's uh really got hounds yeah
that had made the press last week
was she a good stand up in it yes i
think she was saying she was a good yeah
okay she was fine she was all right i
know she never made me laugh really but
but
uh because she's got that way about her
um well no not that one
yeah i don't who cares about that but
the fact that she has this sort of mo
uh means that people pile it on yeah
it's like i'll look at her working she
shouldn't be working
and whatever that story you know what
i've had a show where i had writers and
i
often i'd look at them and say you guys
stink and i hate you
so i the stories about how tough she is
on the writers that i take with a grain
of salt because
well i guess this was there's a natural
you know you got to
crack the whip and also this there's a
natural thing where the person who's on
camera
uh is taking the hits for bad jokes but
would you do it in front of a live
audience what's that would you do it in
front of a live audience oh no
i think that's what the story is about
yeah she did a joke and it sucked and
she goes
why would you write that for me and she
was dead serious well while they were in
break yeah
no she sucks you had good writers on
lucky louie man every one of them it was
funny man yeah
hey what do you call uh lesbians in
australia uh stiff tongues
there's a lot of crying going on out
there
jesus [ __ ] christ i've never seen so
many [ __ ] adults
crying in my life
what is with all the [ __ ] crying i
get it your person didn't win but jesus
christ you're making the left look
horrible
i'm going to canada i love this [ __ ]
where people are like threatening
like share share goes if trump wins i'm
going to go to canada it's like
who gives a [ __ ] you know
i don't even know you was still here
[Laughter]
look i'm not saying i'm happy i wasn't
happy with either one of these people
all right
um but the level of
[ __ ] arrogance of celebrities during
all of this [ __ ]
was just at such a whole other level
do you realize how [ __ ] arrogant you
are that you're making this
you basically you're threatening that if
if your candidate doesn't get in
you're gonna leave the country and your
ego is so [ __ ] big you think
somebody's going like
well i want to vote for trump but
if he gets elected we lose share
i got you babe the [ __ ] out of here
heard barbra streisand really you're
gonna leave [ __ ] malibu to go live in
manitoba
really you [ __ ]
go ahead and do it i'll give you 40
bucks for your house that ought to get
you
9 000 [ __ ] acres up there go on go go
move up to yellowknife
the dumbest [ __ ] but i i literally think
like that's the level of ego that you
have to have
as like an actor a comedian or something
like that literally
to i mean i know i guess i talk about it
but i'm you know i [ __ ] around i trash
people i've never told you guys who to
vote for
or whatever i just trashed them both i
tried to evenly
but that [ __ ] level that people take
it to where they just start uh
you know i kind of was i was on conan
last night which was it was a really
difficult show
uh to do last night because uh
you know you know people are like
[ __ ] stunned out here
they can't believe it um as i can't
believe it in san francisco
berkeley [ __ ] new york city and all
that type of [ __ ]
um so it was kind of weird
it was like going on like right after a
funeral i felt
so um but i really think
this is just my own opinion what do you
guys what do you guys think about
celebrities endorsing a uh
a candidate because i think the
candidates they also kind of reach out
to people a little bit
like like i i've never understood that
like why would i be like
you know who are some of the people you
know some of the [ __ ] people that
have done it like i just don't
understand it's oh oh
you know i was gonna vote this way but
the guy from my three kings
told me to do oh the movie where he
tries to get the sky miles the guy who
did the movie about this guy getting the
sky miles
is telling me this should be the person
to lead the free world
you know i got a lot of feelings on uh
gun control but let me check in with
sean penn first see what he has to say
the level of [ __ ] arrogance
that you have to have i don't know it's
a fine line because it's like all right
well it's good that they're involved
politically
but like you know there's a lot once
you're famous then they're actually
going to put a camera on you and then
you're going to start talking you know
it's the same thing
it's when you become a huge fan of your
team you're a big fan of your team
right and you know you're always sitting
up in the nosebleeds
and then all of a sudden you get a part
on a sitcom and then they got you
sitting down there and then your team's
doing well and next thing you know
they're sticking
the microphone in the face of an actor
right to be
or not to be hey what do you think
buffalo has to do here in the second
half
well i'd like to see you uh i'm checking
down a little bit it's like
i don't i don't understand yet you know
what in defense
of celebrities regular people do the
same thing on the news and
they get away with it because you don't
know what their names are you see it all
the time
on these uh you know when you watch the
news if you ever watch the news they
always go we went out on the street
to ask people what they thought about
this new target that's going up
i think it's going to take away jobs
yeah
you know i just think the downtown area
we don't need that there's always that
[ __ ] person
right so maybe that's what it is that's
that person is no different than any of
those other people it's just
i don't know i think once you get to a
certain level you kind of need to
gracefully uh shut the [ __ ] up
all right